two outstanding French restaurants but
only one can win a place in the
semi-finals
okay the winner today is based on
everything we've experienced Colin you
pulled it back you sort of rained it in
which I didn't expect to see today that
dish delicious Lego eek excelling is
difficult under pressure but you push
the boat out think of the journey when
we started off with edina stunning up
unexpectedly for any restaurant anywhere
in the country that is immense pressure
I mean really immense pressure both
restaurants handled it brilliantly well
after that I then secretly filmed your
restaurants in operation unknown to any
of you to make sure that you weren't
just rolling out the red carpet because
it was me and that told me a lot
so based on everything I've seen
everything I've eaten and everything I
experienced the winner is going to come
down to this the restaurant that I want
to go back to is it that a Gary there
that French charm that real come in and
sit in my front room with an ambiance
that is electric or is it the sumptuous
restaurant with rooms that you walk in
and you're sort of blown away with that
charm tough the winner of the French
category
it's windy and fields
congratulations
John Michell you surprised me today and
you are a credit not just to your
restaurant but your country because you
showed flashes of brilliance don't stop
well done well done well done Ivy
disappointed but at the same time very
pleased with what we've done today need
to take it back to Nigeria and pick it
from there i'm starting him high five
great result for us which I'm really
chuffed to bits with Gordon Ramsay one
of the most famous chefs in the world
telling me that you know he likes my
food and he wants to go back to my
restaurant so yeah I'll beg to get on
top of that you know it's fabulous so
yeah really really really just a bit
winton of things forever whatever I've
been on the most amazing journey of
these two French restaurants it was
quite sad to say goodbye to the Gehrig
however the journey starts now for
windshield fields they so deserve their
place in the semi-final